welcome back everybody we all have to
keep up with our health care of course
especially
as we get older i spoke to a southwest
medical doctor to discuss
how they can help you out so how you
guys doing over there hanging in there i
hope
oh yes we're doing well you know busy as
usual taking care of our older adults
yes and they need special care and
special attention especially right now
so
what are some of those ways they do need
special attention
so you know right now in this time of
colvid
most of us are stuck at home and one of
the things that's happening is that
we've become inactive
so as we get older inactivity seems to
happen
anyway however that affects our strength
our balance our endurance and how
flexible we are
so overall it's really important that we
continue to stay
physically active because it also helps
to reduce our
um risk for falls um
and as you know you may know already
that exercise also has other benefits
like it helps to
kind of aid from depression um helps
it's good for the heart it's good for
the brain and then of course
can prevent weight gain as well of
course and what are some of those ways
to keep physically and mentally active
for older adults
well i mean there are several ways right
so one thing um
that can be done is you know going for a
walk
i know it's really hot right now but we
know when the temperatures get a little
bit cooler
going for a walk if people have a pool
in their home going for a swim
some of our older patients they are
grandparents
so running after their grandkids because
you know all the daycares are closed
so that's been a great form of exercise
for them
um and we also have our optimum care
community centers which which are open
and you know it's another place for our
older patients to kind of get together
make friends and share stories and
the good thing is you well you don't
have to be
part of southwest medical like you don't
have to be a patient with us to
go to our community center oh that's
awesome and i know
you also call them social clubs so
they're a little fun too
yeah so they they have exercise classes
cooking classes
um you'd have to just look up the
schedule to see when
those are but yeah those are happening
what about the non-sports related
activities that people can do oh my gosh
um i have several patients that do um
what is it called square dance
square dancing or dancing i guess
dancing in general
window shopping because stores are open
uh oh gardening
um you know people have become avid
gardeners in this time because they're
not going anywhere so that's another
option
um talking to your friends while you're
just pacing up and down
a lot of my patients do that so that's
another thing to do
and what are some of the good you know
steps for people to take
um after they watch this segment to
start getting physically active and to
perhaps get some more advice and
resources from you guys
well like i mentioned our optimum care
community center is a great resource so
that's one place to start
of course coming to see us in our
any of our southwest medical locations
you know we do have
exercises that and handouts of course
that we do give to our patients just for
those specific things you know to help
build endurance stay flexible and really
our goal is to help prevent falls
thank you dr carr southwest medical has
locations across southern nevada just
call 702-877-5199 or simply head to
smalv.com for more information las vegas
now we'll be right back